it's worth wishing the reason why I am
so Victoria attention to this I was
originally gonna disappear - this is the
question I was alluding to that I was
going to improve - but enough people
have asked me this question this lesson
that I want to show you now okay this is
a whole category of questions very
originally maths teachers have come to
call these questions differentiate hence
evaluate all hence integrate okay if for
example I just made it an indemnity or
you can obviously kind of value eight
that you just get together okay so in
other words just like we've been doing
the whole course you're going to make a
statement about integration on the basis
of something either about attributed
okay so let's just start let it hold out
hand through it and let's see what we
can lose so Part A this is the easy bit
right what kind of knowledge do we need
to purchase any product rule because
it's x times e to the X okay so I'm just
going to go straight into that X DX I'm
gonna get V U - plus you read that are
you happy with that said okay just
straight out so a little bit of
simplifying to do probably but this is
what I got okay yeah by the way just as
a a minor point but it actually becomes
quite significant in this question a lot
of people I want to make note of being a
little bit lazy with their notation and
their writing things like are you know X
e to the x equals e to the X plus X in
the end now obviously what I've just
written is disastrous because quite
clearly this is not equal to that okay
but the fact that you should write this
not the front actually becomes
instrumentally important for this
question watch what is puppy
what is puppet they want us to integrate
the same function it's kind of weird
like I wonder if so you look at this
mode do they integrate do they meet you
and the answer is no they did it they
what are going to differentiate to see
this now we differentiate X EDX because
of the way product works because of the
exponential functions worth X e to the X
the original function it pops up again
it reappears in the derivative I mean
EDX will always do that in some way
shape or form
okay in this case it's really here plus
a number thing okay now this is the
thing I want to integrate that part
there specifically that part there the
reason why I highlight that is cuz I
want to treat this but I don't know how
but I don't have to train this and I
know how to integrate this what happens
if I integrate that it just goes back to
where it started but if you integrate a
derivative you get back the original
function where the constant anymore
okay so watch I'm going to take this
line just as I wrote at the end of play
and I'm going to integrate every single
term with respect to X you might think
that doesn't get you very far but it
does watch on the left-hand side you get
this guy right you just go back to where
you came from cause I'm reversing the
process very here you've got X DX
yes that's the thing you want like there
he is this is a little bit like implicit
last time right where it's like oh the
thing you want it just sort of appears
over spine magic right slope by magic
it's your product I'm sure already say
okay now C is a constant here but I've
introduced over there on the left hand
side well in this part in here e to the
X that just becomes e to the X plus its
own constant okay now because at this
point I've got constants flying around
and I didn't expect that I was gonna
have more than one I'm just gonna go
back and say well I'll just call this
one the first one and this one is just
another one okay they're just more
constants then I'm going to be
together in a second so I've got another
constant now I know nothing about what
these constants are equal to but I do
know if I put it together it would just
be another constant right close it cos
constants or constant take away
clustered still close them so this is
the piece I'm after so I better get him
by himself so I'm gonna write him a B
here the left-hand side that's what I'm
all stop and I'll group everything else
together I have this X e to the X I've
got this takeaway e to the X and then
I've got these guys I'm gonna just mesh
them together and call them 1/3 positive
I don't care what it's equal to because
in a second it will disappear I'll just
beat them ok
then on one step away from actually
getting what I want right
this is an indefinite integral I chant
boundaries don't I
so from here my next line is well whack
some boundaries in there this turns it
into a definite integral I've already
worked out what the primitive is it's X
e to the X minus X to the save forget
about the constant cuz it's gonna get
added and subtracted I didn't think I
really need to finish the question for
me I think you can do this part right
subset you values in tagliata now from
your lower bound and your heart now
pause remember what did I say that you
didn't say well facade is our prime I've
seen this question before and now that
you have this you see these all the time
and basically you're gonna get this and
the piece that you're after will appear
somewhere over here when you have a look
at question 10 the same kind of thing
happens but you need to do a different
algebraic in the algebra you know I will
let you try and work out what different
other anything you need to do it does
sort of something basis is here ok but
notice how like my line of working is
just one line of working right
you went from here to here because I
knew who there's the thing they want to
integrate so I'll just integrate the lot
and I'll work out the rest of it
afterwards
okay in some ways the key is but this is
hard to integrate though this is hard
don't want to do it but this is easy and
this is easy so if the rest of it's okay
I can deal with it which is exactly what
I do okay this has no haps this is
completely rigorous everything is
devastated didn't have to resort to any
tricks you can see and that's kind of
why I had to introduce so many constants
all the way through because I integrate
and then I combine for more than once
but there you go and you can evaluate it
together you have to pull a slightly
different modulation it would just be
sitting there so just really quickly
I'll show you ten there's not the
question you answer so you can think
about it differently I believe you have
to differentiate what was it in question
ten plus product e to the X or plus or
is it mine plus they asked you to do
this and then heads integrate if I
remember this right this is that right
yeah okay now once you differentiate
this what you get this is equal to this
where does this appear in the interview
one it's the numerator this is f dash on
F so it's just the law yes we should end
up with right so that's a different
algebraic trick but in principle is the
same